a então como eu disse essa parte não foi
mentira eu sou de fato o investigador da
polícia civil de minas gerais é por
ordem de acontecimento nelson
investigador da polícia civil
sou psicólogo de formação sou mestre em
psicologia
sou professor universitário faça o cover
dos juros o pai do cristo né
mas antes disso tudo eu sou e aí o meu
apontador não vai funcionar é porque eu
trouxe o computador e ele não vai
funcionar
antes dessas coisas todas têm esse
seminu de mel essa criança sou eu né
razões assim como todo mundo eu acho que
eu nasci careca
tive um intervalo importante entra e é o
dia que eu nasci e agora em que eu tive
muito cabelo esse episódio passou mas
antes dessas coisas de policial
psicólogo professor blá blá blá blá blá
existe uma pessoa ficcionada com
história em quadrinhos estão olhando com
essa imagem vendas tabela criança que um
dia fui né ela tá fazendo o que uma
amiga minha chama de beicinho do
julgamento que eu faço às vezes está na
foto de divulgação e essa criança tá
segurando uma revista em quadrinhos
vocês podem pensar assim o ex menino é
um gênio porque ele usava fralda ao
mesmo tempo que iria revista em
quadrinhos ele tinha algum problema de
desenvolvimento cognitivo e ele usava
fralda quando já era muito grande
não nenhuma das duas coisas não sabia
ler nessa época eu estou segurando este
objeto estranho multicolorido
por que ele caiu na minha mão a gente
tem várias fotos não rolou nessa banda
gente tem várias fotos dessa mesma época
são todos seminu diz minha mãe tá aí
você pode brigar com ela depois em que
eu tô segundo uma revista em quadrinhos
isso que eu não sei ler não sei para que
serve
esses objetos multicoloridos
vamos acompanhar essa foto aí deve ser
por volta de seila a 86 porque ali no
colo da minha mãe tem um pedaço da minha
irmã
e como eu sei que a minha nação inteira
então 86 pela já tinha nascido
toda então tem várias fotos ali que o
coisa não vai deixar eu passar por algum
motivo que a gente não consegue entender
porque ele funcionou até agora minha
mesmo
vamos legalidade novo é sempre assim
obrigados a abrir essa foto é ótima é a
última e aí eu parei de falar eu vou
falar sobre o que quer falar mesmo eu
não faço ideia quando essa foto foi
tirada
ela foi tirada entre 94 e 97 em alguns
marcadores ele
primeiro porque é uma festa no lugar em
que minha mãe trabalhava
minha mãe começou a trabalhar nesse
lugar em 1994 e eu não estou usando
óculos eu comecei a usar óculos e 97
então 194 97 percebam que é uma festa de
fim de ano a gente pode ver aqui tem um
pernil para quem não é de minas gerais
uma comida típica no fim do ano né até
porque só se faz festa empresa em fim de
ano
é eu estou lendo alguma coisa e tem ao
meu lado uma moça até bonita eu sei que
tem porque eu vi a foto porque eu não
faço a menor ideia se tinha e onde essa
moça tiver eu gostaria muito de pedir
desculpa né é daquelas oportunidades da
vida que a gente não vai voltar mais né
percebam que ela está bem feliz assim
colocaram os adolescentes juntos os
pré-adolescentes juntos e do meu lado
tem um pré adolescente jacko que fica no
gibi
pois bem desde que eu nasci
desde que eu consegui segurar alguma
coisa na mão a serviço em quadrinhos me
acompanharam e quando foi fazer a o meu
mestrado eu decidir já tinha um bom
tempo de polícia nos últimos dez anos de
casa e eu decidi que eu queria falar de
alguma coisa que primeiro me desligasse
da polícia e que fosse profundamente
importante pra mim que tivesse
acompanhado muito tempo e eu fui falar
de quadrinhos e aí sempre quando tinha
aquelas rodadas de seminário de pesquisa
essas coisas não é que a gente tem é as
pessoas perguntavam só pesquisar o que
alguém disse eu vou pesquisar os
marcadores genéticos no processo de
criminalidade dos adolescentes o nó é
sensacional
eu vou pesquisar o papel da figura
paterna no desenvolvimento de
comportamentos anti-sociais oculto
sensacional é legal sair
lucas vai pesquisar o que então estou
pensando em pesquisar a representação do
corpo feminino em histórias em
quadrinhos da mulher maravilha das
pessoas e assim que bonitinho é legal
você vai pesquisar de biné não vou
pesquisar o corpo feminino o que vai
acontecer eu vou pesquisar no gibi
no quadrinho na hq como algumas pessoas
dizem que qualquer grande novidade aí a
gente vai fazer tipo chapolin pepe já
tirei a vela e já tirei a vela
obrigado mais uma muito obrigado
então em 1988 surgiu isso aí né
a action comics número 1 uma das
revistas em quadrinhos mais valiosas de
todos os tempos
nessa revista um sujeito estranho
vestindo um colete azul com s no peito
uma capa nas costas e que tinha alguma
dificuldade porque vestiu uma cueca por
cima da calça
levantava um carro sob a cabeça e um
bandido fugir aterrorizado o que quase
ninguém sabe nessa revista marca o
surgimento do superman
mas o que quase ninguém sabe é que eram
dois adolescentes judeus que tinham
criado isso o schuster impossível 2
molequinhos um deles viciado em ficção
científica em romances pulp tinham
criado essa figura incrível né
alguns pesquisadores mesmo forçando a
barra vão dizer que eles se inspiraram
no bernetti do nit né eles não se
inspiraram nisso
eles se inspiraram no que eles viam a
volta deles não nos estados unidos em
1938 não tinham pessoas capaz de pular
mais do que um prédio mais rápido que a
locomotiva e capaz de rebater balas com
o peito isso não existia existia o
oposto disso
trinta e poucos nem 38 a gente acabou de
a gente os americanos não estava lá e se
acabado de passar pela crise de 29
a guerra a segunda guerra mundial estava
explodindo estava começando de vez lá na
europa um ano ou dois depois eles vão
escrever uma história muito interessante
chamada se o superman e se envolvesse na
guerra uma história que saiu de uma
revista caras da época mas enfim tudo
estava acontecendo e tem uma coisa que a
gente esquece
talvez por um distanciamento de memória
que aquilo que aconteceu na alemanha
nazista com os judeus não foi uma
aberração não estava totalmente
descolado da lógica do mundo era comum
se culpabilizar judeus por várias coisas
naquele momento já para provar o meu
ponto a gente pode pensar por exemplo em
o mercador de veneza do sheik que o
grande vilão é um judeu que empresta
dinheiro a troco de um pedaço de carne
do corpo do devedor e que o plano dele
não é tirar qualquer pedaço de carne vai
querer um pedaço de carne do coração é
aquele sujeito morra
esqueci o nome mas lá no oliver twist se
inscreveu
a gente vai ter fabinho judeu é que usa
crianças de rua para roubar as pessoas e
ele fica com o fruto do roubo enfim
quando hitler chegou ao poder eu não
quero fazer uma aula de história aqui
os judeus já são parte da ralé da
humanidade
então só o que ele fez foi dar uma uma
vazão um pouco mais radical do que
algumas pessoas tomavam então imaginem
duas crianças judias vivendo nos estados
unidos pós crise então muito lentamente
na miséria é uma forma de miséria e que
vão criar um sujeito maior do que tudo
um sujeito superpoderoso o sujeito que
na primeira aventura pepe tiro vela por
favor
o sujeito que na primeira na primeira
aventura não vai enfrentar nenhum super
vilão ele vai simplesmente invadir a
casa do governador de madrugada à força
ao governador a dar o perdão um sujeito
que vai ser executado injustamente
essa é a primeira história do superman
ele enfrenta lex luthor
ele enfrenta dark side não enfrenta nada
ele vai invadir a casa do governador é
se a página em que ele invadiu a casa do
governador
o governador de indo tão suja
que vai ser executado o que está
acontecendo aí dois moleques com o
perdão da palavra senhoras bordados já
foi um banho do mundo sente um pouco
mais à vontade
dois moleques judeus nos estados unidos
na década de 30 fugidos eu não tenho
outra palavra desculpa tá em stream
perdão se está assistindo pela internet
não sei a sua idade vão criar um sujeito
que é muito maior do que ele sequer
capazes de superar todos os problemas
que eles têm
isso é tão claro que quando esse sujeito
não está saltando prédios não está
correndo mais uma locomotiva não está
invadindo o gabinete nenhuma autoridade
constituída ele é um repórter do
interior meio bocó e tropeça nas coisas
que não sabe andar direito e que é
ridicularizado por todo o mundo
ora não precisa a gente fazer um curso
de psicologia por correspondência para
entender o conceito de projeção
esses moleques se projetam naquela
figura patética que é o clark kent
mas dizendo olha quando eu quero eu
posso entrar numa cabine telefônica eles
não criaram isso veio depois após entrar
em uma cabine telefônica tirar o terno e
voar por aí
saltar mais alto que os prédios invadir
a casa do governador em mandarim fazer
justiça a essa era coisa que eu queria
trabalhar histórias em quadrinhos são
divertidas num volume muito grande são
produzidos por crianças e adolescentes
algumas pessoas tratam como aventura
escapista mas nunca foi só escape também
foi um jeito colorido de falar de coisas
muito cinzas de coisas muito estranhas
dali a pouco vai surgir uma figura que
foi essa que eu fui pesquisar então não
vocês vêem alguma coisa de mulher
maravilha vendendo no comércio já
encontrei me dar de presente aceito em
41 vai surgir essa figura cercada por um
psicólogo que algumas pessoas dizem que
eram velha com o malandrão que estava
tentando conseguir sucesso a qualquer
jeito mas ele vai dizer sim olha eu
quero criar uma personagem que seja
aquilo que eu acho que as mulheres devem
ser
as mulheres devem ser capazes de fazer o
que precisa fazer
a gente pode questionar as histórias do
chaves volta no começo a ativas ele dava
vazão uma saga sexuais meio estranhas
que ele tinha um negócio de amarrar os
foguetes um símbolo fálico aqui outro
ali mas enfim ele colocava uma mulher
não foi a primeira super heroína mas ele
colocava mulher no centro da ação
sendo mulher não por qualquer história
de violência prévia ela não é uma mulher
sedenta de sangue querendo vingança não
é lei é a deus ama suma nova deus
esculpido no barro pelas amazonas gregas
e que vem ao mundo ensinar um outro tipo
de governança é que ele vai chamar do
domínio pelo amor à submissão amorosa é
o termo que ele usa
e enquanto rafael falava na fala
anterior o que a gente vai ficando as
coisas iam falar se olha tem uma série
de coisas tradicionais uma série de
ações de conteúdos de conhecimentos
tradicionais que talvez nos empurre para
o futuro que talvez vão dizer para onde
a gente vai e não mais esse jeito de
progresso a qualquer custo avanço avanço
avanço uma alta 1 com todos os defeitos
que ele tinha quando ele cria a mulher
maravilha ele tenta projetar uma gente
aprendeu a dizer na academia uma quebra
de paradigma e olha até aqui a minha
mulher maravilha vai bater nos outros
cinco que têm baterias criança gosta né
mas eu quero que ela seja outra pegada
ou não quero que seja só poupou só que
punam quero que tem outro negócio e ele
vai fazer uma versão feminina do
superman praticamente que tem uma
identidade secreta foi ajudinha etc mas
que ali pelos anos 40 e 50
vai estar no top 10 dos heróis mais
amados pelas crianças de então as
crianças amava a mulher maravilha em do
dava como a mais velha mulher maravilha
tinha como seus sua claque né o seu
grupo de apoio a jovens adolescentes
universitárias de pós adolescentes e
universitários é um negócio muito louco
por quê
quando o superman precisava de um
parceiro ele tinha de 1.100 que era um
moleque meio bobo o batman tinha um
hobby era outro moleque
a mulher maravilha não tinha jovens
universitárias ao seu redor
isso diz alguma coisa
o que que as histórias em quadrinhos tem
no fim das contas o que elas estão
fazendo
que novidade elas trazem a única
novidade que elas trazem uma novidade de
meio a gente está contando com o texto
da imagem
algo e no material impresso nem
reprodutível para citarmos ram é algo
completamente velho comum com o qual a
gente já está habituado que o lance de
contar a história não só conta a
história né
não é só dizer alguma coisa é contar uma
história que resolve um problema que a
gente não consegue resolver sozinho
imaginem lá dois adolescentes judeus não
esquece os adolescentes de deus
imaginem dois adolescentes brasileiros
duas crianças brasileiras melhor ainda
cujo mundo que eles conheciam o mundo
inteiro eles conheciam foi arrasado pela
lama
ela passou por cima isso não aconteceu
em lugar nenhum é só uma hipótese
esses meninos precisam receber unificar
aquela experiência eles vão fugir da
lama
num mundo em que eles dão conta de
resolver o problema só como é que eles
fazem isso
eles inventam história quem tem filho
quem já viu criança brinca ano vai
perceber que sempre quando a criança tem
um problema para resolver
ela inventa uma história uma história
que ela tem um papel de ação uma
história que ela inverte os papéis da
realidade
um amigo de trabalho me contava que ele
está esperando o nascimento do segundo
filho e foram dizer que a garota
primeiro filho é uma criança de quatro
anos que eu ia ter que dormir um dia na
casa da vovó para que eles pudessem
trazer o irmãozinho dela ea menina ficou
contrariada mas depois tava lá brincando
a mãe a filha brincando de uma mãe
filhinha os papéis invertidos na criança
mãe ea mãe a filhinha e aí a mãe foi
malandrona falando agora eu vou resolver
o problema então mexer está grávida né
você vai passar uns dias no topa
o meu irmãozinho né e mas eu vou ficar
na casa da minha volta tudo bem aí a
menina respondeu não não minha filha não
precisa se preocupar
eu já liguei pro hospital ou em outro
hospital e que não precisa ficar lá dois
dias eu vou só lá e já volto com o
irmãozinho dois minutos e pode ficar
aqui com seu pai
as crianças fazem isso o tempo inteiro
ela inventou a história as crianças
crescem viram adultos e crescem v1
comunidades viviam sociedades ea
comunidade humana conta a história desde
que o mundo é mundo nessa imagem que eu
acho belíssima
a gente tem uma gripe ou africana os
curiosos na áfrica são essas figuras
sociais cujo papel é contar a história
não é qualquer historinha história que
resolve um problema quem é que já teve a
oportunidade por exemplo de ler os mitos
dos orixás
não tenho umas edições nacionais aí do
prende uma outra do pr e vega que são
excelentes vai perceber que tem uma
moral naquela história mas no amor ao
tipo assim tipo o menino que gritava
logo se você ficar mentindo vai dar
melhor você não é uma moral diferente
alguns problemas são causados por que
você descuidou a culpa é sua
não descuide para não ter problema se
descuidou e surge um problema dá para
consertar desde que peça ajuda a alguém
não tem de fazer tudo sozinho e assim a
humanidade foi criando isso não sou eu
estou inventando isso focar lautau do e
um de quem percebeu que a humanidade
compartilhava histórias muito parecidas
para explicar problemas muito parecidos
talvez a gente pegasse um pedaço de
papel lápis e caneta com as crianças de
bento e deixasse com que elas contassem
as histórias
talvez a gente tivesse histórias muito
parecidas com algumas variações
estéticas com uma mudança aqui outra ali
mas histórias dizendo do mesmo problema
do dia em que elas foram dormir acordar
num lugar muito estranho porque a casa
delas estava embaixo da terra
essa arte da história em quadrinho é
contar alguma coisa que a gente precisa
resolver aí vão dizer se mais loucas
isso lá em 38 né
siga schuster talvez como eu vou mostrar
daqui a pouco um pouco depois mas hoje é
só comércio
sim não o cinema é só comércio teatro
tem uma carga grande de comércio a
literatura tem comércio mas a coisa só
vira a chave só liga quando a gente lê
alguma coisa a gente envolve numa
história diz caramba está falando de mim
o tesouro em seu pudesse pôr lá um
prédio caiu resolver aquele problema se
eu tivesse o peito de aço
lembrei da minha esposa mandando
encaixar o quadril para barriga não
aparecer
se eu tivesse o peito de aço eu não
teria esse problema aqui eu tenho
coragem de chegar na menina que eu gosto
mesmo que ela tem um cara do lado lá
estranho que eu acho que é meio babaca
com ela
é isso esse mecanismo as crianças lêem
aqui também porque quando elas leiam as
malas vêem que dá para ser diferente não
é que pessoas diferentes têm serventias
na falta de uma palavra melhor diferente
mas eu estou me antecipando 212 minutos
e simão jesus maria e josé por favor só
pode ser uma coisa no momento em que
isso ficou ainda mais claro
siga o schuster não era um alienígena se
sentiam como alienígenas tal qual o
superman mau tom não foi feito de barro
e uma mulher maravilha mas tinha
mulheres incríveis ao seu redor
morreu um sujeito recentemente que era
outro veículo também tem um monte de
críticas ao chamado estão ali talvez
tenha ouvido falar ele na década de 60
entendeu qualquer a pegada de negócio
transformou isso em ver comercial que
ele fez ele criou pessoas que pareciam
com pessoas então não passa ainda pede
por favor
neste neste momento nós estamos sendo
homem aranha era um moleque magrelo é
seu e se o título de estreia dele era um
moleque magrelo o óculos fundo de
garrafa sofria bullying
antes a gente tem um nome pra dar pra
isso apanhava de noite um dia picado por
uma aranha radioativa diz
não preciso mais me batia ontem neném
hoje já era
essa é a lógica qualquer adolescente
naquela situação eu pensasse agora eu
vou à forma meu filho agora já era
o que está ali faz muito espertamente no
primeiro número dos olhos se não vai
resolver nada assim
você acha que é só virar o jogo vai dar
bem ó e da ram
quem viu o filme eu quem leu a exibir
vai se lembrar que já na primeira
história porque o peter parker se acha
muito fundão ele perde a figura paterna
dele um vacilo dele é sacada está ali
principalmente mas todos os
colaboradores dele disse tico o camb e
todas essas pessoas da minha geração da
marvel perceberam que era importante
colocar a vida dos leitores no primeiro
plano e então detalhes em o bobô outro
tipo escalar paredes ou bateia pela mão
nada que não desce pra fazer no quintal
de casa né
mas colocar a vida dessas pessoas no
centro
a narrativa fantástica é ótima é
incrível ela resolve um monte de
problema ea gente precisa deixar que ela
aconteça a gente deixar que as pessoas
fantasiam a vida é ótima vida é
sensacional tem coisas que só acontecem
com a gente quem está vivo mas tem
outras porque é que só acontecem ea
gente está vivo
nêga havia da fantasia é meio bocó hamas
é só gente com cueca por cima da calça e
capa é mas também não é quando você está
na lama quando se perdeu tudo quando
acordou um dia num lugar muito esquisito
talvez a cueca por cima da calça seja a
única coisa que consigo fazer é
importante deixar fazer sobre esse
aspecto pesquisar isso o papel do
neurotransmissor na ocorrência do crime
ou o papel da figura paterna na
organização social da sociedade
contemporânea
me parece um pouco mais interessante
interessante porque fala de uma coisa
que eu gosto que eu entendo que eu
conheço e que espero vocês também
conheçam podem soltar os suplementos que
existem dentro de vocês e as mulheres
maravilha e deixem as pessoas
fantasiarem faz parte
muito obrigado
[Aplausos]